[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
this is an urgent plea
to my followers to stop watching my
youtube videos
just for a short while what do i mean by
that why am i telling you to stop
watching my videos
because some of you guys have been
watching me for three years
and you still are financially free
you're still working the same job
you're still doing the same thing and i
feel like some people that watch my
youtube videos
they watch it for almost as
entertainment what's samuel up to
how much weight has he lost how much or
is he put back on whatever
but listen okay i've got a challenge for
you right now
i have a challenge for you it doesn't
involve necessarily watching my videos
i'm not just talking about watching my
videos i'm talking about watching
lots of motivational videos you know
watching netflix doing your usual
routine
here's the challenge you need to become
financially free by june 21st
okay that's soon that's next month
is that possible i think it's possible
i'd say how are you going to do it i'll
tell you step by step right now but then
i need you to stop watching my videos
and just go start doing stuff come meet
me in person if you want
anything different because if you do the
same thing over and over you're going to
get the same results
trying to start doing different things
some start thinking different okay let
me tell you this
service accommodation right now
is blowing up
i can't book a hotel in certain areas
at certain times because everywhere is
booked
okay so you need to find those places
i'll give you a clue um snowdonia
but find somewhere excuse me find
somewhere where you live
okay you don't need to go to snowdonia i
went to snowdonia couldn't get a hotel
so what do you think i did i turned my
houses
into hotels the houses that i was
getting five
six hundred pound a month for the rent
now is literally
you can check it out you can stay at
them it's like three
four thousand pounds per month
i'm a happy boy how does that affect you
well
you can find a landlord that's renting
their property out for five or six in
japan a month
and you can rent it off them on a
corporate
let agreement but saying i don't have
one of those find
a corporate let agreement but i don't
know how to find landlords
go on open rent the equivalent of right
move
with landlords direct ring them
up block the viewing tell them you're
not going to be living
there yourself tell them that you're
going to be
doing it as a corporate let look round
the property
see what they want fix a long-term lease
with a break clause
in case it doesn't work and stick the
property on airbnb
it's not even a particularly regulated
market
sure there's things you need to look for
insurance
if you're doing an apartment headless
but but but you can make
one thousand two thousand three thousand
pounds profit
per month from one deal so what am i
asking you to do
i'm asking you to stop watching videos
on youtube i'm asking you to stop doing
whatever you're doing
and just go and get one freaking
deal that could be financial freedom
that could mean that june 21st
you don't have to go back to work why am
i bothered why am i bothered about
whether you go back to work or not
i don't know why do i do a youtube video
every single day why do i
all the other property educators by the
way they're all jumping up on the scene
now why because
it's popping so much i think i'm
probably the only property educator
that was doing videos every single day
throughout lockdown
and interviewing my success students
every single week on winners on a
wednesday
all through lockdown the whole of 2019
all of 2020
now the hold of 21. but 2021 is gonna be
very different see my videos
my videos are good right my youtube
videos are good they're great
but the people that actually come on
winners on a wednesday are the people
that actually take
action and implement okay so do
something different
hey i'm about to run i'm running a um
a serviced accommodation webinar service
accommodation
101 going through all the ins and outs
of serviced accommodation
you want to join me on that please join
me on that
okay where you can get some advanced
training for free
for free i just give you some advanced
training
get on it follow the training but also
take massive action
get a half your comfort zone do
something different
because the opportunity is ripe right
now and this might never
come again this might never come again
people are going to look back
remember 2021 that's what they're gonna
say
so you need to be one of the people that
take advantage of the opportunity
and take action join me on the webinar i
hope to see you there
i'll leave a link in the description
service accommodation 101 come join me
let's do this together let's become
financially free this is possible i did
it from a working class background
hundreds of my success students have
done it and many of them have used the
service accommodation strategy and it's
never been better right now
brian chesky is going crazy the owner of
airbnb
saying we need more properties on airbnb
go get some rent to rent stick them on
airbnb and booking.com
and make some good cash flow you need to
become
financially free by june 21st
i'll see you on the webinar subscribe
stop watching youtube videos even mine
just start taking action and kicking ass
taking names
okay i'll see on the webinar links below
peace
[Music]
you